-Orlando and I are about to
face off in a water war.
We'll play the card game war,
but if you lose the hand, you
get a pint of water in the face.
[ Laughter ]
We each have
five glasses of water.
First one to throw all five wins
and gets to water-cannon
the loser.
[ Laughter ]
Lots of ways to get wet
but only one way to win.
[ Laughter ]
I have that tattooed
on my lower back.
[ Laughter ]
Orlando. Wait.
I'm sorry.
Wait, wait, sorry, no.
That came out wrong.
Sorry.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
I was just --
I don't have that tattooed.
[ Laughter ]
Oh. Orlando, are you --
are you ready?
-I'm ready, I'm ready.
-All right. Here we go.
-Huh!
-Now, do you trust --
do you trust that these --
-No, I don't, actually, really.
-I mean, would you?
-What?
I've given you
before we start the game.
-I'm going to roll with it,
though.
I'm ready to go.
What do you wanna do?
You want to shuffle the deck?
-No. It's up to you.
Audience, you want me to shuffle
or leave it?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Switch.
Switch.
Oh, yeah, there you go.
Anxious to -- Yeah.
Yeah, baby, yeah, baby, yeah.
-They don't know anything.
They don't work here.
That's what I wanted you to do.
-Oh!
-Yeah!
-Have you seen
"The Princess Bride"?
Ah, so if I do this,
then I say we switch back.
-All right.
All right, here we go.
-All right. Ready?
-You ready?
-No, I'm not ready.
-All right, I'll go one --
-I'm actually nervous.
-One, two, three.
Then you flip.
-Okay. One, two, three.
-Wait, wait, wait.
Just move the first card
over here over the line.
Now we do one, two, three,
and flip it over.
Ready? One, two, three.
-One, two, three.
-Yeah!
-Oh!
Who said flip the cards?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm in my happy place.
It's good.
-It's good?
Oh, this is great already.
-I'm awake.
-This is great already.
-Okay.
-Now, you still have time
to switch the deck
if you really want.
-Okay. I'm ready.
-Do you want to switch the deck?
-No! And, like, now you're
going to whip me, aren't you?
-Here we go.
One, two, three, flip.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Be nice, be nice.
[ Laughter ]
-That is a threesome.
-Three out of the same cup.
All right, now it's game on.
now it's war!
-Ready!
One, two, three.
-One, two, three. Flip.
Damn it!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
One, two --
I feel like that --
I feel like --
What's that film with
Christopher Walken
where it's the gun
sitting on head?
You know the one I mean?
Anyway, yeah.
One, two, three.
-One, two, three. Flip.
Yeah!
-Oh!
-Oh, man, I love you, dude.
-Ah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, ready?
-One, two, three.
-War!
-This is war.
Now, here's what happens.
Ready?
-All right, ready.
-We'll dole out three cards
here.
One, two, three.
And then we pour a cup
into this pitcher here.
Here we go. One, two, three.
-I got one. One, two, three.
Yeah!
Yeah, maybe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait, do I get a gun, too?
Oh! I was like,
"Give me the gun."
[ Laughs ]
Notice I went for
the down-the-back action, too.
A little bit of
down-the-back action.
-And it's cold, too.
All right, here we go.
Oh, God.
-Here we go, baby.
-Why do we play this game?
-Now we'll switch the cards.
[ Laughter ]
-One, two -- Come on!
-Oh!
-No!
-Ace!
Aces win!
-Stop getting that.
-Oh! Oh.
[ Laughter ]
There.
-This game's longer
than I remember it being.
All right. One, two --
-Yes!
I love you.
Now it's this.
-No, now you get the cannon.
-Now I get the cannon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Orlando Bloom, everybody.
Check out "Carnival Row"
on Amazon Prime Video.
Constance Wu joins us
after the break.
-I love it.